bonsoir madame tellier façon va se finir
alors en quoi cette procédure de
destitution pourrait faire obstacle au
nouvel accord canada etats unis mexique
bah ça vient créer une grosse
distraction c'est à dire que l'emploi du
temps de monsieur trempe doit être
principalement occupée par cette
procédure là ça peut durer aussi très
longtemps certains se rappelleront
peut-être que c'était passé avec
monsieur clinton à l'époque il ya une
vingtaine d'années et qui lui aussi
avait fait face à une procédure de
destitution
les journaux ne parlait que de ça on
avait l'impression que la maison blanche
depuis la présidence était un peu arrêté
fuji dans le temps et rien d'autre se
décider et c'est un peu ce qui risque
d'arriver dans ce cas ci c'est à dire
que les décisions importantes et dieu
sait qu'il y en a risque d'être mis de
côté pour traiter justement de cette
histoire d'un pitch parce que c'est
important de le rappeler
l'accord de libre échange doit être
ratifié par les trois pays par le
congrès aux etats unis
exactement et déjà on avait des certain
doute parce que le congrès a changé
cette année et on sait qu'il ya une
chambre du congrès la chambre des
représentants qui est maintenant
contrôlée par les démocrates qui sont un
petit peu moins en faveur de l'accord de
libre-échange puis aussi il faut penser
au canada le canada aussi on doit signer
d'ailleurs on pensait que ça serait
peut-être cet été monsieur trudeau avait
dit possibilité que la chambre
reviennent en juillet ou en août pour le
signer ce qui n'a pas été fait puis
c'est là qu'on se rend compte que dans
les traités internationaux une fois que
s'est conclue il ya c'est bon d'agir
rapidement parce que si on laisse aller
les choses puis on attend ce qu'on pense
être un moment plus propice mais
finalement il peut arriver plein de
choses qui vont faire que il savoir
engendrés pour tous beaucoup
d'incertitudes c'est un peu ça qu'on
voit en ce moment mais que ce soit les
libéraux ou les conservateurs on imagine
que ce sera éventuellement ratifié aux
états unis toutefois le congrès les
démocrates madame pelosi demander des
changements
elle disait récemment que les têtes dès
qu'elle pensait bien que ça allait
passer mais il demandait quand même des
changements
la bonne nouvelle pour le canada c'est
que les changements visaient
principalement le mexique c'est à dire
ça serait que
il ya des lois du travail qui encadrent
qu'il soit bien établi au mexique pour
que ce soit que ce soit juste vis-à-vis
les travailleurs américains par le biais
des lecteurs bailleur canadien donc pour
le canada c'était moins un problème mais
c'est sûr que si le mexique du nom ben
sahar est un peu les négociations donc
il ya toute cette incertitude là qui qui
est en jeu puis au canada pas tout le
monde est satisfait avec le nouvel
accord de libre-échange alors est-ce
qu'on va décider de rouvrir la porte un
peu pour essayer de négocier moi je
pense notamment la gestion du loup la
gestion de la fois pour l'industrie
laitière est aussi monsieur qui a
dénoncé un peu l'accord bon c'était
peut-être une joute politique mais qui
avait dit moi je resigne un meilleur
accord alors est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il rouvrait voter oui pardon s'il
était élu puisqu'elle avait la
possibilité de le faire donc vous voyez
c'est pas des certitudes mais c'est
plein de petites incertitudes de hausser
ce point d'interrogation qui
s'accumulent et qui semblent retarder un
peu la corde la mise en place du nouvel
accord et pour les états unis on voit le
président entre hommes voilà ces hommes
là comme on l'appelle comme étant un
succès de sa présidence dont qu'il
pourrait se retrouver aussi en élections
sans avoir pu faire adopter et ratifier
l'accord
exactement alors lui qui est le champion
des négociations effectivement le satan
me peu moins c'est moins bon ça c'est
pas son bilan
maintenant aussi il veut négocier un
accord avec la chaîne faut pas oublier
qu'il ya d'autres enjeux aussi sur la
scène internationale alors ce qui va
pouvoir vous aussi faire un accord est
d'ailleurs sur les négociations avec la
chine bat les chinois doivent regarder
ça et dire parce que les chinois ont le
luxe du temps c'est ça qui est à leur
avantage ils savent que monsieur tron va
devant l'électorat dans un an alors que
peuvent très bien s'asseoir sur
l'opposition et dire ben on va attendre
que monsieur trompe pas ce prix négocié
avec quelqu'un d'autre et monsieur
tremblante
on avait l'impression qu'il le sentait
que maintenant ça tournait un peu quand
l'huile avantage la négociation alors je
peu près je pense qu'on va voir un
accord conclu rapidement avec la chine
et les états unis
est ce qu'une stratégie de la part des
démocrates carrément avec la l'enquète
sur la destitution de faire dérailler je
connais certains points la somme pour
que dans nos 30 n'en prennent pas le
crédit finalement je ne sais pas si on a
vu jusque là il ya beaucoup de problèmes
internes je pense que c'est plus la
stature de monsieur trump qui est en jeu
en ce moment nous du canada on voit ça
comme un enjeu important mais aux états
unis là ces hommes c'est beaucoup moins
est-ce qu'ils vont profiter pour faire
dérailler
il ya quand même eu des gains pour les
américains au départ ils étaient plutôt
d'accord avec l'alena même s'il y avait
des airs et en plus je pense que toute
la négociation qu'on a eue avec monsieur
30 dernièrement avaient démontré
l'importance d'un accord entre le canada
et les états unis
on ne peut pas se passer de l'autre ça
je pense que tout le monde l'a bien
compris maintenant donc si on essaye de
marquer des points ça va peut-être être
marginal j'ai l'impression mais pas
l'accord dans l'ensemble pas dérailler
tout ce qu'on a négocié est-ce que ça va
dérailler par exemple la législation sur
le prix des médicaments aux états unis
sur les infrastructures également tout
reporter à 2021
mais exactement comme je disais tantôt
là on n'est figé dans le temps alors en
lançant cette procédure l'appui il ya
plein d'étapes dans cette procédure là
on n'a pas fini d'en parler les médias
ont pas fini d'en parler alors toutes
les initiatives que monsieur trempe
voulait mettre sur pied s'arrête vont
prendre beaucoup plus de temps à mettre
sur pied et ça se pourrait très bien que
ça soit ça la stratégie électorale du
parti démocrate s'est pas vraiment
arrivées à lampedusa mais à tous figés
dans le temps pour consulter montré que
monsieur tremblay n'est pas capable de
négocier et donc qu'ils méritent pas
d'être élu on va en parler très
certainement jean pierre tellier merci
beaucoup pour cette analyse ce soir
c'est un plaisir